[Musique]
on le dit on le répète 2020 aura été une
année spéciale pour tout le monde et les
marchés financiers n'ont pas été
épargnés entre chute vertigineuse et
remontée spectaculaire
ça aura été une année mouvementée
lorsque la pandémie explose au mois de
mars
les bourses chutent le nasdaq perd 29 %
le cac 40 35% aux etats-unis ces 33% à
tokyo 28 % catastrophique monde entier
crée alors une crise boursière semblable
à celle de 2008 voire carrément bien
pire alors pour éviter ça les banques
centrales sorte le chéquier la bce ou la
réserve fédérale aux usa se mettent à
inonder les marchés de liquidités
et pendant que les populations de tous
les pays du monde souffre de nouveau
confinement ou de nouveau variant du
virus
les bourses s'en sortent plutôt pas mal
voir enchaîne carrément des records
comme le nasdaq qui sur l'année est en
hausse de 43% en europe et on enregistre
certes des pertes minimes comme le cac
40 qui a clôturé 2020 avec un déficit de
6% par rapport à 2019 des résultats qui
restait alors totalement inespéré en
mars
et c'est justement sur ça qu'il faut
s'appuyer pour tirer au moins deux
enseignements de 2020 1 les marchés et
l'économie réelle sont maintenant même
si c'était déjà un peu le cas avant
totalement déconnecté ça cartonne
même si le monde est à l'arrêt 2 les
marchés sont aujourd'hui plus que jamais
dépendants des banques centrales
là encore ce n'est pas nouveau mais la
pandémie a sans aucun doute
accentuer ce constat cette situation
peut-elle durer combien de temps
l'avenir le dira comme 2020 2021 a
peut-être elle aussi son lot de
surprises pour les marchés